so you see much money coming in at the
moment we are for the Tories we've
barely taken a penny on labor and even
though it's very very short odds on
offer for the Tories to win the most
seats that's now into 1 to 16 today from
1 to 10 yesterday so if you want to have
a bet right now you've got to play 16
pounds to just get one in return that's
how confident punters are and a lot of
for figure 5 bigger bets coming in on
this and that's shifted the Labour Party
out to 10 to 1 we've they're absolutely
friendless in the market right now
interestingly the Lib Dems a little bit
of money for those guys they're into 25
to 1 from 33 to 1
pants obviously think that they might
pick up a few seats Esley they can't do
much worse than last time but it's a
very big mountain to climb obviously to
get the most well that's one of the most
striking things you're quoting all these
bands of seats that the Lib Dems may
pick up the shortest dogs are on 20 to
29 so clearly all punters expect Lib
Dems to do pretty well yeah we are we do
you think they're gonna do significantly
better than last time I think they've
got 9 MPs at the moment but um yeah
there's a lot of money coming in for the
Lib Dems and this explains why Labour
are completely friendless in the market
because they're going to get on some
nice strongholds yeah I can't ever it I
mean the general election is always
effectively a two horse race I can't
remember seeing this long odds on one
participant in a two horse race no
Ladbrokes has been betting on the
general election since in 1960 so we
know a thing or two about betting on
politics but this is the first time in
many many years settling my time that
we've seen such a lob sided one-sided
contest but we're still as excited as
ever to be a part build-up and the
excitement in it what about the SNP what
sort of bets you laying concerning them
so we do think the SNP might lose a
couple of seats to the Tories they're
looking around the 5253 mark if you
think they're going to get the clean
sweep though that's a ten to one so
that's a little bit of a juicy price so
if people fancy them to get all of them
this time and you're already taking
making a market in who's going to be the
next Labour leader so you've always got
no faith in poor ol Jeremy Corbyn you
know there's two sort of hopes in this
world Bob Hope and no hope and frankly
as far as the Ladbrokes trading
department concerned
Jeremy's got no hope he's one to five to
be replaced by the end of this year
kirsten was already the strong
frontrunner at 5:20 replace him but
there's been a lot of money
today coming in for Yvette Cooper she
seen as a very strong candidate another
excellent question - in pmq so a lot of
punters are getting onto the back of
your vote Cupra ten to one
you've only got you've got David
Miliband at 16 to wonder store even NP
though yeah I know it seems a little bit
strange to be money talks and he was
about 33 to 1 the money's been coming in
and we've had to cut the odds
accordingly to manage our liability so
that's why he's as short as he is and in
terms of you keep any interest there
well you keep our actually odds on at 2
to 5 to win 0 seats if you think they
might get one Farrar says he might send
in a self Allen again it's 74 that you
could get at least one seat all right so
not much going on though there Craig not
all right Jessica Richmond lab rooks
thanks for joining me